some breaking news should we and the
energy watchdog off gem has announced
139 pound
increase in the energy price cap meaning
higher fuel bills
for millions of us let's uh find out
about that in more detail should we
joining us
is uh the chief executive of ofcom
that's jonathan
really hello to mr really thanks for
joining us this is going to be really
bad news for a lot of households here in
the uk
what's behind it well we work very
closely with many
charities and indeed with customers and
so we understand this is a very
difficult decision for many households
across the country
and what's behind it is the fact that
there are record fossil fuel prices
globally
not just electricity and gas but we also
saw the same in petrol diesel
and what the price cap does is it does
say that customers need to pay a fair
price for their energy
but no more than that and we're not
going back to the bad old days
where companies will be adding big
profits on top of the price increase
we're announcing today
now our advice to
who decides what a fair price is because
a lot of people will be saying
these energy companies make a fortune
anyway
well what we've seen is the profits of
the energy companies have come down
dramatically since we introduced the
price cap and actually across the market
the profit margin is zero
right now so we are making sure that
companies charge a fair price but what
we can't do
is to ask them to sell energy for less
than they have to buy it for
and with those international increases
in gas prices that's what feeds through
to the price cap
now customers don't need to live with
this though and our message to them is
really clear
get in touch with your supplier make
sure you're getting access to all the
help and support that is available
particularly if you're struggling with
your bills and if you can get into the
market and shop around for the best
possible tariff for you
um you acknowledge though that people
will be pushed into fuel poverty as a
result of this
well we we know how difficult this is
going to be for many customers
but what we can't do is ask companies to
sell their energy for less than they buy
it for
but there is a great deal of help and
support that is available so one thing
we learned during the pandemic and we
were told by
charities like citizen advice is that
many people don't access the support
that's already there
so we'd ask any customer that is
struggling any customer that's worried
about going to fuel poverty
to get in touch with your supplier and
get access to that support that's
available
to give you one example we have
something called the warm home discount
scheme
and that gives people 140 pound discount
on their energy bill
do you acknowledge that people will be
forced into fuel poverty as a result of
this increase
so we accept is going to be difficult
for many families and that's why we
encourage
so if i may my question is do you accept
that some families will be forced into
fuel poverty as a result of this
increase it's a yes or no question
really
so we absolutely accept that this is
going to be difficult for many families
and we accept this is going to change
the economic circumstances within which
they live
that's why it's so important that people
get in touch with their supplier because
there is help and support that is
available
off-chain have put in place really
strict rules that tell those companies
they have to treat their customers
fairly if they're struggling to pay
their bills
now a million people already are on
affordable repayment plans
because they're getting behind with
their energy payments and equally those
companies
making sure you have access to the debt
advice you need because one thing we
find kay
is that people who struggle with energy
bills usually have other debt problems
within the household
and that's when we need some of the
charities due to help
with respect i'm used to ministers not
answering my questions
uh not the chief executive officer of
offgem
28 of families with children at home
struggle to pay their bills
in the last week according to compare
the market
my question to you this morning is does
this increase
mean that some families will be pushed
into fuel poverty it's a yes
or no question so we accept
that this will change circumstantial
families so yes we do accept that that
this is going to be difficult for many
families but my point is
families need to make sure they get
access to the support and advice that is
available
we have worked very closely with
charities with the energy sector and
with the government throughout the copa
pandemic
to make sure we look after customers and
what i'm saying today is we all need to
redouble our efforts
to make sure we continue to do that um
so what do people do if they want to try
and find a more competitive tariff
well you can you can go onto the
internet you can make sure you go to the
switching sites that will
in a few clicks allow you to change to
the best possible tariff and we'd
encourage everybody to do that but we do
accept
that not all families are able to do
that and that's why we want to make sure
that people get access to the wider
supports available
even if you can't switch supplier call
your supplier and ask them to put on a
better possible talent and they will do
so if they can
if you can get through i mean whenever
i've tried to ring my supplier i'm on
hold forever well the
the agreement we just made with the
industry is that they will redouble
their efforts to make sure that we do
contact the most vulnerable customers
and in fact as i've said during the
pandemic you know service levels did
change
as as people adapted to pandemic what
we're saying to those companies today
and in fact what they've already signed
up to
is to make sure they are proactive and
identifying families that are struggling
and making sure they get access to all
the help and support that's out there
what we are doing and what we want to do
with government with charities and with
the sector
is continue to work hard to look after
families as yet another
impact of the kobe crisis is felt by the
energy sector how much can we do that
can we
yeah how much do you regret this
increase
well no regulator wants to put up prices
under any circumstances but the point is
we are seeing a massive rise in the
fossil fuel prices globally
and we do need to respond to that we
will make sure we don't go back to the
bad old days where companies were
charging high profits
but what we can't do is ask them to sell
their energy for less than they buy it
for
so we know this is a difficult change we
know this is going to put families into
very very difficult circumstances
and that is why it's so important that
if you are struggling to pay your bill
get in touch with your supplier and get
access to all the help and support
that's available out there
okay thanks for joining us mr really
appreciate it i know you've got a busy
morning ahead thank you